[Music]
so are we happy as a society that people
who avoid paying their taxes and take
loads of money offshore is that an
immoral way to behave do we need to have
a taxation system which tries to stop
that happening do we need to create
circumstances in our world with
international agreements where we can
stop the kind of flight of capital into
tax havens where they just accumulate
wealth for already rich people and in
our own societies we get fewer and fewer
resources from which to try and draw
public goods and create societies that
we feel are civilized well I would say
yes I think it's immoral actually and
not to have a tax system that that
captures some of those things and if you
were here earlier when I was debating
with David and John you will know that
we talked about a wealth tax
I think it's increasingly obvious that
we have to have a wealth tax and a
global wealth tax will be the best thing
to do because if you have one just based
on one particular country it's very
difficult it so if you look at thomas
piketty's book capital in the 21st
century he made it clear from his
analysis that because the returns to
capital are now greater than the annual
growth rates in most advanced economies
those who are rich and super and super
rich are going to get richer just by
accumulate but keeping the wealth
they've got and getting a return on it
and there's going to be an
ever-increasing concentration of wealth
amongst fewer and fewer people at the
very top and that's not a sustainable
model in which to run our world so in
those circumstances we have to think
about how we can tackle it
and wealth taxes and international
agreements to cut down and make
transparency compulsory in so-called tax
havens are really really important to
the extent that we can do away with
really massive tax competition they call
it that's what I would call a race to
the bottom which just creates
circumstances where you can't collect
taxes at all and it impoverishes the
public realm I mean I think that that is
something that's long overdue for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institutes of Arts and
ideas at IAI TV
you